a lot of text to video models have
recently come out but not only that a
lot of other stuff has happened too such
as multiplayer stable diffusion and open
AI is looking for even more money from
Microsoft stay tuned this is ml news
[Music]
hello everyone as you can see I'm not in
my usual setting I'm actually currently
in Poland it is the last day of the
e-way of the machine learning in Poland
conference this conference is absolutely
glorious absolutely fantastic it was
really cool being here it is over now
I'm going home but next year please be
here or if you're a company that's
looking to get rid of some money and
sponsor an awesome conference the ML and
pl conference has been organized at
least as well as any of the new ripses
or icmls that I've ever been to and it
is very likely that this conference is
going to grow and become more notorious
in the next few years there was a great
lineup of keynote speakers tutorials and
other content and I even had the
pleasure of joining into a bit of a
concert at one of the poster sessions
which was certainly a unique experience
so thanks again to the mlnpl organizers
see you there next year alright so
stable diffusion is going multiplayer
this is a hugging face space there's
it's essentially a giant canvas and you
can just come in here and you drag this
Square somewhere and you give a some
kind of a description and it will just
kind of fit in what you're doing all of
this is collectively drawn by people and
I'm always afraid because I don't want
to destroy something right because all
of this is just very very cool what
people come up with just another example
of something that I would have never
thought of but because stuff is open and
release this is you know this can be
built so absolutely cool give it a try
and maybe this inspires you to build
something that is even cooler than this
I don't know what it's going to be but
I'm sure one of you has a great idea
right now another hugging face news they
introduce DOI digital object identifiers
for data sets and models dois are sort
of a standard way in scientific
literature of addressing things like
addressing papers addressing artifacts
and now hogging is introducing these
things for their models and data sets on
the Hub so on the Hub you're going to
see this little box with which you can
generate essentially it's a uuid for a
model or a data set that is never going
to change in the future now you can
outdate it so you can say well this one
is deprecated I have a new version of
this model but it is a unique identifier
to that model that you have this is
really good if you want to put it inside
the paper so as to make it reproducible
and given that it is a standard it just
incorporates with the whole rest of the
scientific ecosystem so definitely a big
plus for anyone who does work in
research Wall Street Journal writes
Microsoft in advance talks to increase
investment in open AI this article
essentially there isn't much detail but
open AI is apparently asking for more
money more investment Microsoft has
previously invested about a billion
dollars into Microsoft and on top of
that probably really preference access
to Azure in exchange that openai will
provide preferential access to Microsoft
for its product it's funny because here
it says last week Microsoft announced it
was integrating Dali 2 with various
products including Microsoft design a
new graphic design app which is cool and
the image creator for search app Bing
like really is that their big plan is
that the one billion dollar investment
to get Bing off the ground finally I'm
not sure now keep in mind that just
because open air goes and asks for more
money that doesn't mean that they're
bankrupt soon it could also mean that
they're planning for an even bigger push
startups and I don't know if open AI can
still be considered a startup but
startups often they do take on more
money whenever they want to start
scaling even more now how much open AI
wants to scale even more I don't know it
could also be that they're just out of
money and need more the stack is a data
set it's by the big code project and
it's 3 terabyte of permissively licensed
source code so this data set is fully
open you can download it if you want to
train anything like a codex model or
something similar the data set pays
specific attention to the licensing of
the code that is included in the data
set the code is MIT licensed Apache
licensed bsd3 license essentially
licensed such that you can do whatever
you want with it now that doesn't get
you out of the weeds legally of doing
anything and everything because you
still have to you know do things like
provide a copyright notice if you copy
one of these codes verbatim but the
stack not only pays attention to this
when they collect this initially but
also as you can see on the hugging face
entry in the hugging phase top there are
terms of use for the stack and one of
the terms of use of the stack is that
you must always update your own version
of the stack to the most recent usable
version and this is because they have
essentially form where you as a source
code author can go and request a removal
of your source code from the stack so
even if you license this under MIT
license they don't want anyone's code
who doesn't want to be part of the stack
so you can go and request that your code
be removed from the stack they will then
do that update the data set and by
agreeing to these terms if you download
the data set you essentially agree to
always download the newest version and
use the newest version of the data set
such as to propagate that removal of
that code now as I understand it I'm not
a lawyer this is not legal advice but as
I understand it you are entering into a
bonding agreement by clicking this
checkbox and clicking this button so you
know think about whether you want that
or not but it is good that another
option is out there next to just
scraping GitHub I guess Google releases
vizier open source vizier is a black box
Optimizer that works at scale so many
many different EXP experiments that need
to be hyper parameter optimized this
year essentially decides which hyper
parameter to try next so you can run
this as a service if you have a lot of
parallel workers and you want to run
hyper parameter optimizations they have
apis for users and the user here is
essentially someone who wants to do
hyper parameter optimization they have
apis for developers which means that you
can put in new optimization algorithms
so if you're a developer of a black box
optimization algorithm you can integrate
that with vizier and they have a
benchmarking API so apparently this
thing has been running inside of Google
for a while and now they finally decided
to release it open source so it's
certainly tried and tested alright now
we get into the video models there have
been a few video models now they have
been released a while back but I'll just
summarize them briefly here imagine
video is a text to video model you can
see a bunch of samples right here and
they look really really cool so this is
a video diffusion model but as far as I
understand it is kind of a combination
of fully convolutional networks and uh
super resolution networks in order to
get this effect they describe this
further in a few diagrams on their
website using imagine video uses video
unit architecture to capture a spatial
Fidelity and temporal Dynamics temporal
self-attention is used in the bass video
diffusion model while temporal
convolutions are used in the temporal
and spatial super resolution models
there is a paper to go along with it if
you are interested now also from Google
research is fenneke I'm not exactly sure
how to pronounce that but it is a
different text to video model that can
produce up to minutes long videos with
changing text so here you can see a
prompt that constantly changes and as it
does the video changes as well so rather
than being a diffusion model this model
compresses video to a token is
representation and then essentially uses
a causal autoregressive language model
to continue that tokenized
representation with that they're able to
essentially produce unbounded video as
the beginning of the video Simply drops
out of the context but as long as you
feed them to the side input more and
more text that you want to be produced
you can see that the video keeps
changing keeps adapting and keeps being
faithful to the currently in Focus part
of the prompt what's interesting is that
the training data seems to be mostly
text to image with just a few text to
video pairs inside of the training data
now we're not done with the text to
video models yet meta AI actually
released make a video yet another text
to video model and this one is also a
bit special because it essentially only
produces a single image from text so
this is a essentially text to image
model and then
unsupervised video generator from that
image so the text to image model is
essentially as we know text to image
models but then the video model is
unsupervised it simply learns from
unsupervised video data how video
behaves and is then able to take a
single picture and let a single frame of
that video and make the entire video out
of it the results look really cool and
what I think is cool between all of
these works is that they all have a
different approach for the same problem
the all the results they produce are
very cool and it's going to be
interesting to see how this text to
video problem will ultimately be like
canonically solved let's say I don't
know but I'm keeping my eyes open now
slightly different but not entirely
different is dream Fusion this isn't
text to video this is text to 3D now if
you think that you know is relatively
straightforward then the whole none of
these things actually in of 3D training
data at least as far as I can understand
it rather what they do is they consider
the entire scene essentially like a
nerve so what they do is they start with
a random 3D scene so pick your 3D scene
and fill a bunch of voxels and don't
fill the other voxels and then you
optimize that 3D scene to satisfy text
to image models that essentially act as
photographs of that scene so it is is a
lot like Nerf except that you don't have
pictures but you like optimize for a
text to image model rather than
optimizing for an actual image and that
is a really cool idea and actually seems
to work pretty great now there's other
work still improving text to image
diffusion models themselves
Ernie vilg 2.0 is one of them this is an
iteration of the previous model and it
is using mixture of denoising experts I
don't want to go too much into this but
you can definitely see right here that
the results are breathtaking and very
good with a great resolution now there
is a demo on the hogging face Hub but as
far as I understand this model isn't
released so the demo and the code that
they put on GitHub they simply calls
some API where the model is actually
stored
foreign
this is a neat tool not directly related
to machine learning but if you've ever
wondered what like the difference
between a b float 16 and an fp16 is I
never knew but Charlie Blake has a very
cool tool on a Blog that essentially
shows you the different trade-offs you
can make when you choose a number format
so it shows you for the different
numbers what kind of ranges you can
represent with them where they're good
at where they're not good at so you can
see here clearly the difference between
a b float 16 and an fp16 one can
represent a lot of numbers and the other
one can represent just very small range
of numbers but to more Precision Gridley
JS is a tool that allows you to interact
with grid World reinforcement learning
environments so there are a number of
cool features right here you can edit
levels directly you can also try out the
levels you can debug your policies you
can record trajectories so right now I
don't have a trajectory but what I can
do is I can click record right here and
I can move this thing around here here
going to the lava and then I die and you
can see the steps I've taken right here
so you can use this to do various kinds
of things debugging investigating and so
on if you are into reinforcement
learning and you work with grid world
then by all means check this out meta
announces their new box I guess this is
the Box this is an architecture for a
deep learning the Grand Teton
essentially they release the
architecture open source so their
Engineers have sat down and thought long
and tired about what it takes for a
great machine Learning System like
they're a bit more older bgx boxes and
they essentially tell you look we
believe that this combination of
Hardware this processors these gpus
connected like this with these power
supplies will be a very great days for
doing research yeah they're releasing
these specs essentially for you to just
buy or assemble I guess whatever you
want to do with it but I can't tell you
it is relatively hard to decide exactly
on every component of the hardware and
it's really great that people who are
very competent in this actually think
about it and give their suggestions so
if you have a lab or a company and you
really want to buy your own Hardware
maybe this is a good option for you
hugging face diffusers from version
0.5.1 on forward supports diffusers in
Jacks if you like Jax if you like stable
diffusion go for it Muse is an open
source stable diffusion production
server well it is not as much a server
as it is sort of like a tutorial on how
to bring up a server this is based on
the lightning apps framework which is
open source and it's kind of an easy way
to bring together all the components you
need to deploy machine learning things
and this repository is essentially a
specification on how to pull up a stable
diffusion server so if you want to
deploy stable diffusion yourself this is
probably the fastest and simplest way to
do so erlx by car for AI is a library
that allows you to do reinforcement
learning for text models so you can see
right here you can give either some sort
of a reward function or you can give a
data set that assigns values to expert
demonstrations and you can train a
language model to incorporate that this
is a relatively new domain to do
reinforcement learning on text models
but it is cool to have another library
to tackle the problem RL baseline's 3
zoo is a training framework for stable
baselines 3 reinforcement learning
agents stable baselines is a library
that tries to give reference
implementations of reinforcement
learning algorithms because they're very
tricky and they're very hard to get
right so these are good solid and
performant reference implementations
stable baselines three is the third
iteration of it and this repository
right here the zoo contains a number of
surrounding things like scripts that
make it very easy to interact with it
but also prepared agents and prepared
hyper parameter settings that work well
in different standard environments Jax
set is a library that allows you to
train very large language models in Jax
so the cool thing is that with this
Library you essentially get things like
data parallelism or model parallelism
for free you can just specify them and
you can trade them off however you want
this is due to the power and simplicity
of Jack's albuminations I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly 1.3 is out
and it introduces a bunch of new image
augmentations this is a library or image
augmentations so it's good that they
introduce new augmentations that fits
very well to the augmentations they
already have there's also a bunch of bug
fixes and more if you're looking for
image augmentations in Python this might
be a good Library this is a really cool
thing you can do with diffusion models
these people have trained diffusion
models of brain images and were able to
create new synthetic brain images with a
degree of controllability now there is a
paper on archive if you are interested
you can also download the data set of
100 000 synthetic brain images code
Geeks is a multilingual code generation
model this is as it says it's
essentially something similar like codex
but it is released you can actually go
and you can download unload the model
and use it yourself meta AI releases AI
template which is an inference engine
the goal here is to make inference
faster they get a lot of speed UPS over
just running standard inference in
something like high torch so this does
two things first of all it optimizes
your computation graph if your
computation graph contains a lot of like
little operations that could be used
together into something that's really
optimal for a given Hardware or just
that can be expressed in a smarter way
than a graph Optimizer can do that and
in a second step there is a compiler to
compile all of this to highly
performance C plus plus code that runs
on backend Hardwares such as a GPU that
uses Cuda or even an AMD GPU so if fast
inference is a concern to you this is
definitely a thing to check out Nerf
Studio describes itself as a
collaboration friendly studio for Nerfs
but it is more like a collection an
entire collection of software to handle
nerves anything from training validating
or even experiencing yourself you can
see they have a viewer that allows you
to just explore the nerves that you do
and make little videos from it but
really it covers everything to do with
nerves now speaking of Nerf Nerf hack is
a pie torch Nerf acceleration toolbox
this gets significant speed UPS over
simply using nerve code that's out there
for example vanilla Nerf model with
eight layer multi-layer perceptrons can
be trained to better quality in one hour
rather than one to a days as in the
paper these stack the logo doesn't
exactly work on dark background but this
stack is a library that wants to
standardize your ml workflows that you
run in the cloud this is essentially you
check your workflows into GitHub and
dstack helps you to run them uniformly
anywhere so in a workflow you can
specify things like your workflow name
obviously but then it starts you can say
okay my provider is Bash so this is
essentially A bash script now what are
the commands I want to pip install some
stuff I want to run this training script
right here but it also has things like
artifacts and you can also specify
things like I want to load data from
this S3 Bucket over there I want to run
on this Cloud over there so all of this
is quite geared towards machine learning
it's certainly not the first workflow
engine or the first iteration from hey
let's check our things into source code
but it is very targeted at running ml
workflows in the cloud several people
have figured out massive speed UPS in
the open AI whisper model for example
this person here has figured out a 3X
speed up on CPU inference but refers to
a GitHub thread where someone else has
found an even bigger
3.25 x speed up again it's very cool to
see what people do when you just give
them the model
and lastly I want to point to a couple
of databases for Stuff mainly around
stable diffusion so diffusion DB is on
the hogging face Hub it's a data set of
Romans that have been entered by real
users into stable diffusion and the
corresponding images that they got out
public prompts that uh publicprompts.art
in your browser is a database of three
prompts and three models these models
are mostly trained using dreambooth but
if you're looking for inspiration for
prompts and what they turn out and this
is maybe a good place to go likewise
visualize.ai is a website that goes a
little bit more businessy so it lets you
create some free stuff like stable
diffusion but then it also acts like as
a bit of a Marketplace for these things
such that you could also buy them or
sell them it's cool to see that
different business models are trying to
spring up around this ecosystem
ultimately someone will figure out how
to really make money off of this stuff
but you know it's good to be part of the
time when people are just trying stuff
and seeing what happens with not only in
the research side but also on the
business side and lastly big science has
released prompt source which is an IDE
for natural language prompts so this is
a way to give people a bit more help and
a bit more standardization when they use
prompts to achieve certain goals for
example when they use prompts to tackle
some of the NLP challenges that are now
more and more phrased simply as prompts
into these large language models rather
than as data that goes into a specially
trained model for that task so if you
find yourself in this situation or a
similar one then prompt Source may be
for you and lastly this is a database of
all Lex Friedman podcasts transcribed
this is the website of Andre krapati and
he used a simple combination of a
download script from YouTube combined
with open ai's whisper to transcribe all
of Lex Friedman's podcast episodes you
can go to any one of them you can click
and they are here with time annotations
and all is a very simple but very cool
project thank you Andre and I thank all
of you for listening I'll be home again
next week until then stay hydrated bye
bye
[Music]